you should have drawn a quadrilateral
and I wanted you to do your best so
thank you for a dural not special it's
not a square
not a parallelogram not a rectangle not
the quadrilateral which we're doing a
special property but one that is as
general as you do all the signs are
different none of the angles are the
same all that kind of thing okay now
here's I want you to do follow these
instructions carefully but I think
you'll find they're pretty easy to
follow if you have another color there
this will be immensely easier with
another color and preferably with a
ruler because the more accurately you do
this the more sort of the effectively
whether all of what I want you to do is
to bark out to locate an in mark out the
midpoint of each one of the four sides
of your under special quadrilateral okay
measure it out make it it's accurate
least accurate as possible right mark
out all those good points and once you
have the mark down do better carefully
I then want you to join those midpoints
because you have four sides so now you
have four points and we can make them
before classes of MU quadrilateral okay
now once you've got your four points and
you join them up I want you to look at
your shape and then I also want you to
look at the shape of the person next to
you have a look so have you looked at
the shape that you created have you
looked at the shape of the person next
to you as well who hopefully had
decidedly different quadrilateral should
begin with and then suspiciously very
suspiciously have created with these
midpoints a whole new shape which
despite your best efforts to make a non
special quadrilateral
well you just cleared a very special
preserve what do you make it's a
parallelogram right some of you
depending on the original set you made
maybe you even accidentally created a
rectangle because rectangles are of
course a special quote special
parallelogram
where you add what what do you add you
add a cigarette penalty group like this
right what would I have to do to these
Paulo has to change them into rectangles
yeah angles or both okay yeah sure so if
you want to think about in terms of the
angles here how they relate to each
other that would work and create a
rectangle there's a super way to think
about that and have to do it though a
rectangle you guys do my obsession with
names right uh you guys know what angles
are what's the prefix of rectangle me
where where you see this word this for
like for example in Africa a picture
hanging on the on the wall right into
frame right and you say hey it's wrong I
wanna read your fight what's that mean
makes you wanna you want to make it
better much politically it's not it's
not correct you want to make it right
don't you
isn't that what you want to do in fact
that's what contigo means it means right
angle so all you have to do is take a
parallelogram and put it right angle in
it because if you have opposite angles
in a parallelogram what's their
relationship to each other in a
parallelogram just look at it what's the
relationship between these two they're
equal right it's a bit more of this on
this one very cool and that means that
this pair is also useful so if you put 1
1 right angle inside the parallelogram
what happens well that makes the
opposite angle also right angle which
makes the other two you also ready so
all of a sudden you put one end you've
got forward so why is this the case and
if you haven't done this already go
ahead and I'm adding those indicators
saying yeah you sure enough created a
parallelogram and even when you've got a
polygon which you know most people
always everyone is drawn to be like this
I always get confused uncoated concave
or a convex polygon
I think it's Club X anyhow oh yeah there
are those sides that go inside the shape
is what I'm referring to all of the
angles are either acute or obtuse as
opposed to like this
tangle in here but even she created this
one which further reminded me is one of
the cases you can do he doesn't care
he'll still make a parallelogram now my
question is why this is one of the
things that I love about geometry
geometry is just it's just magical right
it just does things that it doesn't
really explain why until you dig a
little bit okay now what's up if ever
we've been in Rizzoli what's the stop it
we've been in coordinate geometry and
Lydia functions in particular okay
which is why I hopefully because it's
internal you became about why it shows
you the shape now there's a variety of
ways to prove that if you have an
arbitrary quadrilateral if you join the
midpoints of the silence then you must
always without exception create a
parallelogram but being that we're in
the topic of geometry I want to show you
how we can do this using a coordinate
system okay so I asked you through this
half an airport page what I want you to
do is superimpose on top of that some
corner axes you do that for me just for
the right spec bag in the middle
now one of the beautiful things about
this is I heard the questions just
anywhere and the answer is yes just
anywhere because remember when I asked
you to draw this quadrilateral what
kinds of rules did I set for you about
the four points that you're going to
draw what instructions that I give you
pretty much nothing there are no
qualifications in fact I try to make
like 80 qualification unless don't do
anything that would make this unusual
literally put them anywhere okay so
there's no rules that find any of these
points to each other or even to
themselves I mean I've drawn them in all
four quadrants but you can put them all
the first budget if you want it one
second or wherever you like so how do we
go about proving this I'm going to pause
from it
I've given you this clue in that one of
the most efficient ways to do this is by
corner geometry but I'm going to pause
and give you a couple of minutes to
think I've said this before and I'll say
it again one of the most important
phrases in in curricular services when
learning mathematics is the phrase
unrehearsed context unrehearsed context
this is a question there is that
opposite of everything you've had to
deal with in the past of here not done
fifteen of these and now do one more
that's just like all the others just
with different numbers okay
I've never asked you to do anything like
this before maybe you've been exposed to
simple in this maybe if you did the
Richman series before live it at school
but all I'm going to give you is this
premise number one you can look at this
to the lender quarter geometry number
two if you start with absolutely any
quadrilateral we have observed we've
experimented as it were we're taking a
scientific approach with repeated be our
experiment twenty four times twenty-five
twenty-six times okay we've seen okay it
looks like it happens right and we
repeat it it seems to be true but in
mathematics we don't care if you
experiment we don't care if you observe
it a million times that's not enough for
us we want logic and division this is
always true you want to generalize
something to me about five minutes to
ponder aDNA think you're welcome to
actually talk with other people to try
and focus an idea but if I can have a
standard first on your own how would you
go
proving that this shape here must must
always be a parallelogram and I think
would you have an idea call your life